i think when i originally began the work
so this bodywork restarted almost 30
years ago and I'd say at that point I
mean I think I had a sense that there
was a a political undertone and the work
but it wasn't the motivating factor you
know it wasn't that you know I I wasn't
feeling that I was going to I was making
this work as a concerned photographer
trying to create change in this area I
was I thought chronicling a kind of
movement that I saw were where our
populations were growing at exponential
rates and and you know I was focusing on
the the resource extraction industries
and coming to trying to understand
visually what's changed and what to me
was changing was that we've always taken
from nature so we are the ages of man go
back to the Stone Age and the Iron Age
and the Bronze Age and the copper agent
these ages of man are all kind of you
know chronicled you know throughout the
apology so we understand that you know
we've gone through these but these ages
are so we still get stoned we still get
copper we still get iron but this scale
and speed of that taking has changed
dramatically and so I felt that the
large format camera and having worked in
those places because I did work in a
mining mine and I'd seen them that what
we don't see we don't see the scale of
you know we see the scale of our cities
so here we are in a city new york city
and scale is you've never seen ever saw
a city before and you came to New York
could be overwhelming to see all the
tall buildings you know just the sheer
volume of a built world that we've
created here but when I you know when I
was going there and photographing that
other side that to every act of creation
there's an equal or greater act of the
struction and that we only take a
portion of the good stuff but there's a
lot of waste that's laid to you know
that before we get to the good stuff
whether it's the wood that we take or
you know if we take metals from or we're
only taking me be five percent of the
volume ninety-five percent ends up being
tailing so we're really disrupting much
larger grandeur scales of landscape so
to me that was an interesting thing to
begin to try and find the yin to the
yang you know the the destruction to the
creation of the things that we build and
but in the landscape and at a certain
point I began to understand it as a loss
for nature that as we were expanding
nature was being chewed away and then I
began to understand the work as a kind
of uh that there was a kind of
melancholy or sadness to it but it was a
lament for the loss of that place that
we've called nature that it's losing out
in this battle between what we need and
what's available and where it's found
and and so wherever that place is is
being hammered you know for for to
supply the things that we need so and
then I began to see nature is really
just an open cupboard where you know
we're just were raiding the cupboards
you know and taking everything as
absolutely fast as we can and now you
know and as I've kind of gone on to to
begin to understand that you know I see
our oceans as a you know opening up the
covers and just attacking it you know
with the ferociousness that is like
breathtaking so I think the work never
was intended to be political but the
political reading as a result of our
becoming more aware of the collective
human impact on the planet is coalescing
to I think give the work a political
undertone or reading that with maybe
either ones more than I originally
intended but the intention was that it's
a multi that the work is unstable in
that there's it has all kinds of
features to it that there's the content
in the form so it makes an image that's
interesting to stand in front of and I
wouldn't go as far as saying beautiful
but at least compelling to want to look
at it to want to enter it and then once
you're in that place it's a question of
do you want to read it for its form and
the kinds of structure that and the
color and the things that are presented
in a scale of the things I'm presenting
or you can just you know and and
somebody can even enjoy it on this year
aren't humans interesting look at what
they're building you know to you know to
to the idea that you know is within the
work there's a lot of embedded
documentation as well of how we mined
for iron or how we mined for copper you
know how we build what we build and you
know in terms of buildings and you know
there's a lot of stuff that photography
just carries forward as well that
defines an era and a time in a style of
how we did things